how did we get here I mean literally not
just you and me but the whole shebang
how is any kind of life possible the
universe is a hostile Place solar flares
cosmic rays asteroids flying about the
odds against our existence are truly
astronomical
take it from me I'm an astrophysicist my
job is to look out into space at stars
and galaxies trying to answer these
basic how did the universe come to be
questions
well those who have a religious Faith
have an answer God the Earth's distance
from the Sun the size of the atom and a
thousand other things large and small
that allow us to live and to breathe and
to think all seem perfectly tuned for
our existence to many this design
suggests a designer but from a purely
scientific point of view the faithful
have a big problem they can offer no
indisputable proof for this belief
because of the lack of Hard Evidence
it's probably not surprising that over
70 percent of the members of the
National Academy of Sciences declare
themselves to be atheists but they have
a big problem too absent a Creator how
do they account for the existence of the
universe of planet Earth of human
consciousness how do they account for
the existence of anything
well it turns out they have an answer
and it's become all the rage in
scientific circles it's called The
Multiverse and according to many
scientists our universe isn't the whole
ball game far from it these scientists
argue that there's an awful lot of
universes out there not just one or two
but an infinite number of them let me
explain
13.8 billion years ago there was a big
bang from something unimaginably small
we don't know exactly what the universe
exploded into existence how did it
happen why did it happen doesn't matter
because it happened immediately after
the big bang the universe underwent a
rapid expansion think of a gush of
bubbles exploding from a seriously
shaken soda can just after it's popped
open cosmologists call this the theory
of inflation as the universe inflates
and expands the bubble universes grow
and separate to become their own
distinct entities each with their own
unique properties
in other words new universes are spawned
and not just a handful an infinite
number of them
some of these universes would be too
cold for life and some too hot but with
an infinite number surely one is bound
to get it just right in short you and I
are just an accident that given enough
universes was inevitable but wait
there's more because there are so many
universes it's very likely according to
the Multiverse scenario that everything
that could possibly happen does happen
in one universe or another that
girlfriend who broke up with you you're
married to her in Another Universe
does this sound a bit far-fetched a
little too science fictiony well not the
Nobel prize winning scientists like
Stephen Weinberg or the famed
cosmologist Stephen Hawking as well as a
myriad of others who wholeheartedly
endorse him but here's what's really
surprising they endorse it knowing
there's not a single shred of hard
scientific evidence that supports it and
how can there be there's no way we can
access Another Universe
in short a vast number of the world's
most eminent scientists believe in
something that hasn't been and in all
likelihood will never be proven how does
that sound to you
probably the same way it sounds to the
distinguished physicist Paul Davies
invoking an Infinity of unseen universes
to explain the unusual features of the
one we do see is just as made up as
invoking an unseen Creator the
Multiverse Theory may be dressed up in
scientific language but in essence it
requires the same leap of faith or as GK
Chesterton quipped when men stop
believing in God they don't believe in
nothing they believe in anything for
Multiverse Believers this is literally
true the same scientists who reject
God's existence due to the lack of
evidence pin their hopes in a theory so
all-inclusive and vague it could never
be refuted
those who believe God created the
universe are intellectually honest
enough to admit that they do so on the
basis of faith but those who believe in
the Multiverse are also Keeping the
Faith they just don't admit it
so let me ask you who's taking the
bigger leap
I'm Brian Keating professor of physics
at the University of California San
Diego for Prager University
thank you for watching this video to
help keep trigger you videos free please
consider making a tax deductible
donation